the NATO Secretary General says
Ukraine's potential membership will be
high on the agenda When leaders meet for
a summit in July yen stoltenberg is on
his first visit to Ukraine since Russia
invaded last year he met with President
Vladimir zielinski who reiterated his
wish for fast-tracked membership the
Kremlin says preventing Ukraine from
joining the military alliances one of
the key goals of the invasion
and go live now to Charles Stratford
he's live for us from Kiev so
we've got some warm words coming in
Charles from Jen stoltenberg is that
match with warm policy
[Music]
well certainly it matches with what
zielinski would like
um zielinski has repeatedly asked for
NATO membership and according to
stoltenberg and the NATO allies it's way
too early to realistically start talking
about that let's not forget that one of
the prerequisites for joining NATO is
that there be no border conflicts
happening in a country that is applying
for membership and certainly no
International
conflict happening anywhere near it and
of course we've got both that happening
now in Ukraine we've already had
reaction from Moscow as you mentioned
Dmitry Prescott the Kremlin spokesperson
saying that one of the goals of what
Russia describes this Invasion as being
Russia's special operation in Ukraine
was to prevent Ukraine joining NATO and
it's widely understood that indeed back
in 2014 the annexation by Russia of the
Crimean Peninsula and indeed Russia's
support for so-called protest in the
donbass region was all to do with
scuppering that plan but it seems as if
seriously that zelinski's words are
being taken seriously by Yen saltenberg
and Ukraine's NATO partners and let's
have a listen to exactly what
stoltenberg said in the capital Kiev
earlier today
let me be clear
Ukraine's rightful place is in the Euro
Atlantic family
Ukraine's rightful place is in NATO
and over time our support will help you
make this possible
we've also got this anticipated spring
offensive what else is zelenski
requesting from NATO Beyond membership
of course
well as you can imagine zelinski's
continued his demands for more weapons
we've already seen tens of billions of
dollars worth of Western kit flooding
into this country over recent months and
we know that certainly there are
thousands of Ukrainian soldiers that
have been pouring into the donbass
region and the south in recent weeks in
preparation for this expected so-called
spring counter offensive so yes zelinski
asking for more weapons the ukrainians
have been pretty candid certainly saying
that there are huge holes in their
ability to defend the skies
um interestingly yesterday Germany
confirmed that its pledged Patriot
missile system the second Patriot
missile system the first one being
American has now arrived in Ukraine but
that is nowhere near enough we know that
ukrainians are demanding for example
more fighter jets and more
surface-to-air missiles to try and
protect their eyes so yes weapons like
this very much at the Forefront of the
agenda today it's going to be very
interesting indeed to see what happens
tomorrow Thursday when NATO officials
meet in the German Ramstein Air Base to
discuss giving more weapons to Ukraine
in the light of uh widely expected for
this counter-offensive to start in the
coming weeks and months all right thanks
so much Charles Stratford there
Hungary has banned the import of some
meat products from Ukraine as part of
efforts to protect Hungarian Farmers
it's in addition to its existing ban on
grain imports from Ukraine Poland
Slovakia and Bulgaria have introduced
similar bands after a fall in prices
triggered protests from local farmers
but shipments are allowed through the
countries on route to other markets
thank you
so Masha balikova is a reporter at fast
markets Agri census she joins us now
from danipra in Ukraine good to have you
with us so Ukraine's neighbors they've
imposed these grain bans antagonizing
the EU has this resolved do you think
the issue or is it just the beginning of
more complications
even there was a ban for imports from
Ukraine uh the countries has agreed that
uh like every country Bulgaria Poland
Hungary Romania Slovakia they all agree
that Transit is still going on and there
is also final decisions from the
European commission expected
because uh those countries are not
really
able to act like this and do such uh new
rules new terrorists sorry new rules
yeah for imports uh like individuals so
everything that is done in the Blog has
to be decided in Brussels
but what we see uh from Ukrainian
perspective of course it has already
created uh the cues on the borders and
it has already caused some losses for
the people for the traders who have been
delivering the grains by the tracks and
by wagons because for example for
Bulgaria
um the wagons and the trucks are staying
on the border for almost three weeks
already because Bulgaria has introduced
are your control so they are checking
the quality for the Grain and this is of
course not good for our uh our trade our
Ukrainian Market but I don't really
think they're going to ban and this is
not exactly my idea but what the trade
thing about this and of course it's not
really going to affect the European
prices as well because the stocks for
the grades uh were already high in the
European Union and currently the whole
Market the global market have been on
the downside so and many of the main
buyers are covered for the for a few
months already so it's not really
something that we're going to expect the
increase of the prices in
European countries that will allow their
Farmers to sell at higher prices all
right but we're already seeing as you
mentioned uh trucks trains carriages
piling up at the border how is that
hurting Ukrainian farmers and the
Ukrainian economy if it can't get grain
out
ah well it's a tricky question because
on one side if you're talking about the
whole country and the whole expert the
expert
for Transit mainly that was going from
Ukraine to the European countries is
only around 23 percent of the whole
grain not really grain but agriculture
product that is going out of Ukraine and
and Romania's share is something around
15 16 persons and most of that is going
through virtues from you sorry so from
this perspective it's not really that
big amount but of course for the Traders
and for the bombers who have been
oriented for European market and who
have been selling there of course for
them it's a big issue for now because
they are just facing about this and this
is not something that our farmers happy
to see because the prices on the
domestic Market in Ukraine have been
already pretty low
and it's not just grain now hungary's
increased the number of Ukrainian Goods
which are banned from being sold
domestically to 25
items how much of a worrying development
is that for the Ukrainian economy
and that we are happy to see especially
uh as there are also some challenges
that Ukraine is facing regarding the
grain Corridor because
inspections are not going the way they
want the the way they have to be so uh
all these bans and restrictions in
European Union together with all this
uncertainty with a black sea Corridor of
course that's all forcing some
um worries and concerns
uh I can't really tell you what is the
laws if there would be stoppage of not
just crane but all their agriculture
products that they are going to ban for
import now into Europe because it's not
something I do I do follow but yeah of
course it's some money and all the money
that Ukraine is losing now is hurting us
because our economy you know is not in a
very good position because of the bar
and maybe we should also talk about why
we saw prices start to crash for grain
in some of these neighboring countries
that surround Ukraine
so it's not the uh well
if we start from the beginning
uh when the war just started uh last
year
the prices for all the grain Commodities
have been have been reaching the new
highs like ever high levels uh of course
because the whole Black Sea region which
is one of the key region especially for
the reach production and experts have
been affected
uh and um from the beginning when it was
uh when Ukraine was just figuring out
how to manage the expert
[Music]
um Romania Bulgaria and some other
countries have been using this situation
and have been selling at much better
prices not just those countries but all
the countries in the world who were able
to cover the demand
and
um the crisis started to fall uh when
the corridor Geo was signed but actually
they started to fall even before because
it was already something that people
were believing in so uh the optimism
about this great deal was increasing so
and pushing down the prices and also for
me
especially one of the main thing that
also affected the prices was when Russia
okay in uh last yeah in last year I'm
afraid we are running out of time so
we'll have to leave with them
mashability cover thank you so much